what about changes in mate preferences
what they look for in men when women are
at the point in the cycle when estrogen
is high there's been a lot of research
indicating that women exhibiting a
preference for more masculinized male
faces more masculinized male voices the
scent of testosterone and so there's
been a lot of research that sort of
links estradiol to testosterone
preference so more recently researchers
have begun to explore the idea that
women who are on hormonal birth control
given that it keeps your own estradiol
levels very low that this might be
associated with a decreased preference
for masculinity there's been research
showing that women who are on hormonal
birth control prefer a less masculinized
male face relative to what's preferred
by the exact same women when they are
naturally cycling The Men Who were
chosen by women when they were on
hormonal birth control those faces were
seen as being less masculine and also
sort of scored lower in terms of
masculinity using the objective measures
relative to the faces of men who are
chosen by naturally cycling women